oh what a feeling we're going to begin
this hour with tennis superstar rafael
nadal as you just saw
he won his 14th french open singles
title yesterday thank you very much 17
years after winning for the first time
back in 2005. now nadal extended his
record number of men's grand slam wins
now to 22
and the 36 year old is the oldest man
ever to win the french open is 36 old i
don't think so
his lifetime record in that tournament
is 112 wins and three losses the doll
beat 23 year old casper root of norway
in straight sets yesterday despite a
chronic foot injury that flared up we
are very happy to say that rafael nadal
joins us from paris areas good morning
to you rafael nadal congratulations
hello good morning thank you very much
good good morning and happy birthday to
you i know you just celebrated your 36th
birthday i'm thinking that's a pretty
cool birthday present we just saw your
expression when you won what was going
through your head in that moment boy
your face said it all
well uh yeah thank you for the
for the birthday and uh
well that uh at the end of uh
uh an event like roland garros uh when
when you finally win the last point of
course there is plenty of emotions now
and the last couple of months haven't
been easy for me in terms of
an injuries uh so even even more special
so yeah have been uh
yeah an emotional moment
how will you able raphael to play
through the pain listen i have achilles
tendonitis i'm walking around with one
of those very attractive boots and all i
do is walk from a car to a studio studio
back to a car i can't imagine how you
could play in such pain
well
we're used to it
first of all yesterday and uh
and the at the end of the day it's uh
it's about passion and about uh
how much you love what you do and uh
during all my tennis career i think i
had the determination to
to to keep going doesn't matter the the
situation and
that brings me to to the position that i
am today that is
unexpected without a doubt because at
the age of 30 seeds i thought i will be
doing and other things not playing
tennis 10 years ago
but here yeah i mean i can be happier
raphael your your finals opponent casper
rood was six years old when you won your
first french open now in most walks of
life other sports the younger person
usually has the advantage how is it that
you could beat these guys over and over
again given your age given the injuries
given how long you have dominated in
this game does it say much more about
how cerebral tennis really is
well casper is a great guy we know each
other very well because he have been
in the academy uh for for a couple of
years already
and uh
well in some ways especially not to to
to combine uh the generations because i
think a lot of
young players today watch
us
play
on on tv when they were kids
and we were very young players so they
grow watching us on tv and now
face
uh each other
in the biggest
stadiums of the world it's always uh
special no and for me it's it's yeah
it's a special be able to
to to feel myself competitive against
the young
the young players and they are good and
at my age be able to
to
to keep being competitive against
against everyone uh well it means a lot
to me honestly
raphael you keep mentioning your age you
said you didn't expect to be playing
tennis anymore at 36. you are arguably
the best tennis player of all time
you've won more grand slams than anybody
else
what keeps you going at this point
well i like what i do first of all i i
enjoy uh
my life on the tour
and uh
i don't know i i
i would love to keep going so let's see
how the things evolve the next couple of
uh
weeks months
and i hope to to have the chance to
to keep going and play again in in the
us open that i missed the the tournament
the last couple of years and it's a
place that i like so much so i i mean
new yorkers are very happy to be back
because since i defend
since since i won my my last title there
in 2019 i i was not able to be back on
on
on flashing me there was no so i am i am
excited i'm trying to come back and so
let's see if i am able to to make that
happen
well a lot of people are hoping that
that's true i know you said you're up in
the air about wimbledon but it's good to
hear that you're at least thinking you
want to come back to new york because
really we will be here with open arms
waving our raphael pompoms
many thanks thanks thanks everyone hope
to see you there